well the debate on the second referendum
is raging in the Labor Party and today
the people's bake campaign have released
a survey of 25,000 people suggesting
labour could fall sixteen points behind
the Conservatives if they allow brexit
to go through well joining us now is the
Labour MP Chaka Munna thank you very
much for being with us happy new year
well I guess we're hoping first of new
year fresh start try and get some
movement when it comes to the gridlock
that we've seem to be in your answer to
all this is a second referendum
how many MPs do you think are now in
support of having another vote I think
first of all we've actually got to have
the meaningful vote on the prime
minister so-called deal I'm not going to
be disingenuous and pretend that we have
the numbers for a people's vote on the
terms of our withdrawal from the
European Union right now but obviously
what happens and now and happy before
now will be very different after we've
had that vote let's be absolutely clear
the prime minister gave the pledge on
the 17th of December at the despatch-box
in the House of Commons that we would
have that meaningful vote in the week of
the 14th of January now she doesn't hold
that vote
she arguably will have misled the House
of Commons and there will be moves on a
cross-party basis from the back benches
to ensure that the will of the house is
tested on whether or not they wish to
support her so-called deal so that's it
what would happen if the government yeah
there are lays the vote again there have
been reports that's right there are
various parliamentary tools that we can
use to illustrate the will of the house
and frankly if the government doesn't
comply with the terms of the EU
withdrawal at 2018 which provides for
government to do a statement on the 21st
of January and then there's a
determination as a motion will forward
as to what will happen next then
arguably the government would be in
contempt of Parliament and so they
should be in no doubt that if we have
further delay which would be grossly
irresponsible
we've got 82 days to go to a brexit exit
day just over 11 weeks and one thing
that people who may not necessarily be
convinced of a people's vote are
convinced of is of the need to avoid a
No Deal brexit none of our constituents
I think voted for that
and they certainly didn't vote to make
themselves poorer either I mean I feel
that none of you very small number
perhaps of European citizens would like
to see that year and one of the most
remain supporting constituencies in the
country that's right in other parts of
the country polling shows that actually
there is a significant number of people
who would prefer a No Deal for example
the Prime Minister's do well I don't
think we can say categorically one way
or another what the will of the people
is actually in 2080 you're right you're
right to pick me up right to pick me up
on that but frankly that is the whole
reason why we've been arguing for the
last few months for a people's vote to
determine what it is now because 2016
was one thing but we don't really any of
us can none of us can really say for
certain what the will of the people is
in 2018 not least you know there are
over 2 million young people who can now
vote who couldn't vote before who polls
would indicate overwhelmingly do not
want to see the country going down this
trajectory and I think look for the
Labour Party let's not forget that in
2017 a huge number of younger
generations voted for the Labour Party
hoping that we would take the country on
a different trajectory and I'm not sure
we will be forgiven for robbing them of
their futures if we don't actually give
them a say on this the because you see
no blame labour for that
I think they'll blame it with a plague
on all your houses but given that you
know we know that younger people
overwhelmingly have been supporting the
Labour Party of late it's quite clear
that they're not going to look well on
the labour party that they see
threatening their future prospects we've
all got to bear we've all got to bear
that in mind in my view one thing that I
am struggle to get my head around is
that the people's vote campaign is
trying to push through a referendum that
many people will see as divisive many
people will see it as a betrayal of the
first referendum and yet you can't even
agree on the details of what that would
be what do you think should be on the
ballot paper because it seems that
whenever I ask people I get a different
answer well ultimately this is something
for Parliament to determine and let's
not forget though if you a campaign well
hang on just a minute how in just a
minute if you look at the people's vote
campaign we have people from the left to
the right of politics we've got
nationalists from the SNP from plied we
have people who have a different view on
things all together in this big
10 so from a point of view of unity of
campaign I don't think asides us for not
having the collected group of people I'm
quite clear that clearly the current
deal that we have as a member of the
European Union the government's own
research shows this is the best deal
that we could possibly have so that has
to be on the ballot paper and I do think
you have to have a option on that ballot
paper that would please the likes of
Peter bow that is a hard brexit so to
speak those two choices is in some way
shape or form would need to be presented
to the British people and of course what
you know the position we're in now is
very different the argument we were
having before two years ago was based on
hypotheticals of what could happen if we
voted to leave the European Union now we
actually know what will happen we have
much more of a concrete picture and we
know that you know however you vote
either in three options then well I
would say two or three I'm pretty
open-minded about it but ultimately it's
for Parliament and of course the
Electoral Commission to determine but by
the way let's just be out you know let's
not presume that the Prime Minister's
deal isn't going to pass many people
have been focusing you think it might
past who knows because we don't know
what she's going to announce she's going
to be going on another program in an
hour's time we don't know what she's
going to say there we don't know what
she's going to be here we don't know if
she's going to be say in Parliament this
week and I don't think we can be
complacent the problem with this deal is
not only the backstop which people have
a concern threatens a territorial
integrity of the United Kingdom it is
that for the first time certainly in our
lives we have a government pursuing a
course which it has already told us is
going to make our country poorer that is
an extraordinary thing this deal that
she's putting forward to people is going
to do a measurable damage to our economy
I mean there's a certain irony in the
man on Sunday today she is saying that
if MPs don't vote for a deal it's going
to threaten jobs she's already put out
research her own economic impact
assessments showing that her deal is
going to threaten people's jobs and
businesses in this country I want to
talk to you about no deal because it's
nearly something that people on your
side of the argument are very concerned
about can Parliament actually stop no
deal happening because surely it's the
default position if you can't agree well
it's a very good question
legally there are two things that would
need to happen
first of all in order to change exit day
which is stipulated in law to be the
29th of March of this year
Minister will have to put forward a
regulation to change that date now we're
unclear as to whether that necessitates
a vote of the House of Commons but it
would have to be at the initiative of a
minister secondly we would have to get
an extension to the article 50 process
from the European Union and this is the
key thing for me
I accept that there are some colleagues
both on the Tory and the Labour benches
across the house who have misgivings
about having a people's vote but there
is one thing the European Union have
been absolutely clear about if you want
an extension to article 50 we are not
going to grant you an extension to give
you more time for renegotiation as has
been mooted by some that is not going to
happen but we will grant you an
extension for a democratic vote so the
people's vote if in the short - the
medium term you want to avoid No Deal
that is your route to stopping our
country crashing out of the European
Union in a very disastrous way another
important point I'm Sophie it has been
mooted in the papers over the last few
days but if the Prime Minister fails to
get her plan through the House of
Commons she will simply keep bringing it
back again and again to the House of
Commons I've consulted with the class of
the House of Commons on this you cannot
simply bring the same motion again and
again and again so according to the
Clarkes she cannot bring it you cannot
do that and even if say you sought to
bring a different motion through
changing one word if it's in substance
it's the same thing under the rules of
the House of Commons
you can't just breathe bringing it again
and again and again and what I would say
to the Prime Minister is listen to the
House of Commons she turns up every time
gives us his e-statements tells us her
deal is the best deal Parliament says no
including on her own benches and she
tries to ignore it you cannot carry on
putting your head in the sand when we
have the clock basically is still
ticking and that she should be a no
doubt certainly in terms of what the
back benches are saying where so many of
the initiatives for on brexit seem to
have been coming over the last few
months we will not stand for a No Deal
scenario and we're not going to allow
her to simply delay this vote further
there are different parliamentary tools
at our disposal and we will use them and
just finally if you heard of CNP no
according to Westminster gossips and
Evening Standard its chukkas new park
well they're gonna happen well let's say
two things about let me tell you two
things about that
these two think this thing this concept
arises in two scenarios one when the
people's vote campaign is going
full-throttle and making a success and
brexit ear voices frankly at the Labor
Party and the Conservative Party peddled
this nonsense the second thing is when
the ugly face of anti-semitism rears its
head in the Labor Party - and what this
is used is a huge deflection exercise
from the real issues here first of all
the Glade party has to deal with
anti-semitism as I've said to you before
on this show and secondly let's stop
messing around let's focus on the real
issue here who is it gonna happen then I
don't think oh look I want us to stop
this disaster that's happening
everything else is deflection everything
else is distraction and I don't get to
determine these things as I said you
know in terms of any new parties all
that it's not for me to determine as
I've said to you on this show before
that's for the leadership of the Labour
Party and frankly the Conservative Party
- they want to keep their parties
together that's for them not for me okay
thank you very much